I get more consumption on my LinkedIn
than CNBC gets viewers that's absurd
that makes no sense you cannot
comprehend what one thoughtful
two-minute video can do for business
development we're the fastest growing
independent agency in advertising in the
world our entire business model is my
content of LinkedIn we spend nothing on
sponsorships no
conference events no booths nothing
LinkedIn free attention is the number
one
asset thank you for having me uh there's
a couple different ways I can go with
this so let start with this and then
I'll decide uh based on that in this
room how many people are familiar with
me and consume my content please raise
your
hand okay that
hurts so I guess I'll be going left um
all right let me actually then with that
I thought that might be the case and so
what I'm going to do is give you four or
five minutes of context that will set up
what I want to talk about here which is
these 12 and 1/2 attributes But first
you know know prepping for this back to
the Clapping it up instead of clapping
for people up here if I just may louder
than we just did for him I am just
incredibly impressed of the Journey of
this I I live in and have only run two
family businesses most of my clients are
private Equity or public companies
there's probably not many things I enjoy
more than a properly at scale run
private company and so if I just may I'd
like you to clap it up for each other
and so if we can just do that that would
be very
[Applause]
nice and no I genuinely meet it
I get to do this a lot I analyze a lot
of businesses I run a 2000 person Global
advertising agency right now we look at
it I started my agency to go to be an
infrastructure for all the private
Equity Behavior I plan on doing as I'm
on my path to buy the New York Jets
and so I'm uh thank you brother It's
Hard Out Here For Us Jet fans I needed
that um so I'm really excited about this
talk because I do this a lot for a
living but like the mix in this room and
the format of this business is
interesting even if you look at the like
it's really hard to balance number six
and seven right like balancing kindness
and tenacity for the makeup of this room
and your framework's super interesting
you're all one big family but some of
you are like weirdly willing to cut each
other's throat for more business in
here and so I think there's plenty to
talk about I think I'm going to focus on
two core things which is culture uh and
content but because most of you don't
have context I will spend three minutes
if I may on telling you why I believe in
these two things and I think the
backstory will help I was born in the
Soviet Union I came to the US in 1978
when I was three so I don't really
remember uh that part of my life but we
grew up extremely poor as you can
imagine for some of the ogs In This
Crowd you may actually even remember the
Carter years the economy wasn't super
great and so I lived in a studio
apartment roughly the size of this stage
with eight family members for the first
two years that I lived in America my dad
got a job as a stock boy in a liquor
store in New Jersey and that's how our
American Dream started we moved to
Edison New Jersey that's where I kind of
started my entrepreneurial career when I
was six seven and uh you know I started
with like six or seven lemonade stands I
somehow manipulated or tricked or
inspired my friends to man and woman the
lemonade stands and at the end of the
day I don't know if some of you remember
this remember big wheels before you get
a real bike you get a big wheels I used
to literally at like 6:00 at night in
the summer ride my big wheels to my six
locations and pick up my cash like I was
Tony
Soprano but what I was doing and this is
what I want to talk to you about when we
get to the content side
which is why I'm I mean I was already
pretty thrilled about this talk with the
makeup but when I understood that
there's a real commitment to the
LinkedIn thing that I see and I'll get
into underpriced detention the next book
I'm writing in a
minute I've been chasing underpriced
attention my whole life the reason I
wasn't Manning my lemonade stands when I
was seven was cuz I was actually sitting
on the corner of streets in New Jersey
as a 7-year-old this is like how sick I
am and how much this was in my DNA and I
would literally watch Cars drive by and
try to figure out which tree or which
pole to put the sign on that gave me a
better chance to sell
lemonade when I was 14 after spending
several years selling baseball cards
which by the way when you're you know
when I was 11 and 12 doing baseball card
shows I would also set up my table that
way with
attention and you know I was making ,000
$2,000 a weekend at like 12 and 13
selling baseball cards and I don't know
about you but back to entrepreneurship
which I know a lot of you will associate
with when you have like $5,000 in cash
under your bed and you're 13 and you're
not selling weed you're doing a pretty
good job so it was always in me and then
I was killing it and living like you
know 5,000 bucks a 13e like
trillionaire especially in the 80s but
then my dad dragged me into the liquor
store that he now owned cuz he lived his
journey and at 14 I started stocking the
shelves of my dad's store in Springfield
New Jersey and um that was the worst
because he paid me two bucks an hour but
somewhere around 16 I realized that
people collected wine and that's when my
infatuation with building the biggest
wine company in the world started and
then it all fast forwarded into me
launching one of the first e-commerce
websites in America in 1996 called wine
library.com and in a 5-year window on
the back of email on the back of Google
AdWords and on the back of blogging
before social media became the primary
opportunity I built that business from a
three to a $75 million business in a
5year period with no Capital not even a
credit line cuz my dad didn't believe in
it that became the foundation of what I
want to talk to you about growing stuff
I just saw some of the Ambitions 500
million 2027 all the stuff getting a
sense of the DNA in this room I do think
it comes down to in 2023 2024 and Beyond
in these two hard core Seas which is
content and culture culture I think is
incredibly unique because especially as
I started digging into the founders
story and especially when I think about
the makeup of the room of the ambition
and the growth and the sales
DNA I I'll use American political terms
to set up where I want to talk about
which is the world
increasingly both in clearly in politics
but even in the business world and our
realities really fall into the category
of red or blue and the reality is all
the magic is in purple
you know and when I when I look at these
things when I think about gratitude
let's start there you are not in this
room if you're not winning back to
clapping it all up I think people have
completely lost context of gratitude
living in a first world country like
America like just to remind everybody to
level set where I'm going with this the
top 1% earners in this country you know
the one of the two dominant empires in
the world right now at a very rich
company the top 1% earners in this
country start at about $440,000 a year
if you make $440,000 a year you're in
the 1% in the richest country in the
world even different than that from a
business standpoint looking around this
audience we are all of the age where
some bad stuff has happened we've lost a
relative we have lost things when I
think about why people don't build good
cultures especially when I think about
this which is you're the
hunters and back home on your team are
the
farmers and that framework ex excites me
and I think about it a
lot just the complete and utter not like
lack of ability to understand how much
gratitude if it actually is in you how
much that shows up with how you manage a
team is huge we lost Ford as a major
client my head person that runs all of
the New York office which is the biggest
office and the Ford account runs in and
when I tell you white as a ghost I'm
talking like Casper the Friendly Ghost
white like whiter than that like dead
walks in he's like we lost Ford and
we're talking about eight figures Hefty
I'm on my computer I look up at him I'm
like okay I'm like let's deal with it
later he had come from all these
agencies where like what would have
happened is complete chaos 100 people
would have been laid off blah blah blah
blah blah blah that doesn't come because
my p&l is healthy though it is enough to
absorb it it comes because I'm
incapable of letting business dictate my
emotional behavior I'm completely
detached from my suc when I say 5.3
million fans back the story he just told
you I'm not proud of that I mean I'm
proud of it I know I put in the work but
it's not like it's definitely not my
identity and I think when I think about
winners at this level I always think
about like man if people were just
really grateful because what I always
think about and what I said earlier I
know there was some Chuckles since I was
10 I've been on a mission to buy the New
York Jets I think about it I strategize
against it I own an Esports team and a
pickle ball team and uh you know like
with other owners in the league Steve
Ross the owner of the Dolphins owns a
piece of my agency like I'm I'm in it
and I'm trying but when I think about
balancing real obnoxious
ambition compromising
it and changing your culture because
you're so so driven by a number a goal
success is actually stopping you from
getting to the thing you want for me
it's the same old game that I always
play back to gratitude and I'll move on
if everything was going awesome If today
was the day that I bought them and then
I get a phone call and the most
important people in my life are hurt or
truly terminally ill or the worst of
worst have just passed in the last
seconds or minutes where am I
and I really think we struggle with that
I think when you're winning and you're
succeeding and you're driven which is
what every single person clearly has to
be doing here in this room I think we're
completely detached from gratitude and
if I could challenge you to be grateful
for what you have versus obsessed with
what you don't have yet forget about
even business and how I think it affects
your team just think it's going to make
your life better something worth
debating I think you know I think about
self-awareness a lot the other unlock
that I've SE seen in this scenario that
I'm spending a lot of time thinking
about with the CEOs that I sit on the
board of I was uh this is why I have
some audacity of buying the Jets um in
2006 as I was going through building my
dad's business I decided social media
was the next big thing and I became a
very early investor in 2006 in Facebook
Twitter Tumblr Uber back then literally
Facebook Twitter and Tumblr were the
first three companies I ever invested in
they were remarkable if you don't know
Tumblr it was an early it's basically
The Social Network that I think Tik Tok
is now representing the interest graph
versus the social graph it sold for a
billion dollars to Yahoo 10 years ago um
but in self-awareness I've had funds
since I've done well but I haven't
annihilated it and it's because I'm not
really a remarkable investor I'm a good
investor but now I'm becoming a better
investor because I've asked myself why
did I invest in those companies I
invested in them because I wasn't
thinking of myself as an investor I was
thinking of myself as this is a good
company the CEO is good I'm going to
make money I simplified it I think for a
lot of people in this room as you think
about doubling tripling quadrupling what
you want I think we struggle in lying to
ourselves at some point I'll get to my
half which is kind cander if you ask me
why have I left enormous amounts of
money on the table in my 25 years and
all this success it is completely and
utterly attributable to my inability to
be canderous to my team because I don't
really love negative conflict I like to
find different ways to get to the goal
without telling people it directly to
their face it's something I've struggled
with for 20 plus years only in the last
three or four years when I've been able
to assess personal and professional
hardships that I've been able to really
go to a self-awareness accountable
honest place with myself and it's
completely transformed our business in
the last four years my agency has
doubled in size of people and tons of
growth single based on me finally
addressing my cander issue and not
surprising PE the only thing that was
up my culture and my culture is
off the charts was that I am so proud
and I challenge all of you to understand
how important as a leader it is to
singly be focused on eliminating
fear period if you want to melt this all
down to the opportunity for growth how
good are you Steve first of all great
shirt Steve Steve how good are you at
eliminating fear is a direct correlation
to what's going to happen to your
business with people the problem is
there's a lot of parents
here how many people are parents in here
raise your hands so a lot of you know
this the problem is when you focus on
eliminating fear and you go too far you
create
entitlement and so my vulnerability was
I'm so obsessed with eliminating fear
that I created an culture of
entitlement and so people thought they
were better than they were because I
wasn't able to tell them and so finding
the purple instead of the red and blue
is a humongous passion of mine and so I
highly recommend for anybody in this
room who genuinely is hungry for the
growth to start thinking about
self-awareness even some of the stuff I
talked about earlier this whole one team
thing you're on in a world where you're
all kind of independently playing like
you have to be self-aware of like who
you are as a partner to this ecosystem
more importantly and I mean more
importantly even though I'm sure that's
incredibly important more importantly
you have to be self-aware of the leader
you are for your team
your retention and happiness on the
people that work for you has the
craziest direct correlation to your
growth
capacity and so I think in the business
world all these foofy foofy feelings
especially in and I'm a
Salesman especially when we think about
sales and hunting I think we've grossly
underestimated that the soft skills are
actually the hard skills and I know what
a lot of people think when I talk about
this stuff I am not talking about wild
entitlement for genen Z who wants to
work at home five days a week and not
work and wants you to take care of
everything but I do want to remind all
the people that raised your hands we're
the parents of those kids my favorite
thing that's happening in culture is
having dinners and meetings with people
where they're on their
23-year-old kid and then when they're
done I look at them I'm like you created
them you don't want your kids to be
entitled don't give them eighth place
trophies when they suck in
soccer
I mean for people over over 40 raise
your
hand this where you go to school
and argue with a teacher for a better
grade that's some crazy ass like
we've broken way too many rules of Merit
that's why you want to talk about why
everyone's scared and sad it's because
we've scared them we've shown all our
children that the reason like here's a
good one if you have a child that's over
22 years old
in your life right now and you give them
money in any capacity you pay for their
apartment their Uber their Equinox you
just give them money I will show you a
direct correlation to them being
unhappy but yet it feels counter and
this is the same thing with management
just like parenting I don't think what's
up here is so easy balancing being
empathetic to your team and kind while
you're tenaciously trying to hit numbers
is a tight RPP but I promise you
there is a direct correlation to it and
I don't know you well enough I don't
know who is not tenacious enough even in
this room of winners I know some of you
have hit your cap you're good you're
you're not hungry anymore you're you're
you hit a thing and you're like now
you're in neutral you're like this is a
good number this is where I'm at and for
many times for good reasons you feel
like you didn't have the right work life
balance you do have 15 and 16y old kids
and you're like wait a minute they're
about to go to college in 2 minutes I
haven't like maybe you're higher I
there's a million
reasons but I think that's why number
two means so much to me lying to
yourself is the quickest way to
lose and I'm stunned how good we are at
it and when I think about talks like
this like in this exact Nano second I'm
like man if one person is listening
right now in this room and decides to go
to their hotel room tonight look them in
the face and stop lying about something
they're not good at in this or even
their personal life that's how you
actually that's what therapy does that's
what real stuff does and I'm telling you
I challenge you to understand especially
in the framework of this business
especially by the way complete side note
putting up the rankings of everybody's
numbers in front of you that's some
gangster
the the concept of let's be a
family but look John's better than Sally
kill each other
this is what I mean by purple this is
why this was so exciting for me I'm like
this company's kind of like me like
this is weird it's like let's be like I
created this Pokemon meet Sesame Street
intellectual property that I'm building
another one of my Avenues to get to my
goals it's going really well and one of
the star characters in that world is
kind
Warrior that's a really brain twist
right like how can you be like a
gangster but be deep in business and be
deeply kind and I know what's happening
in the world right now we're really in
this generational Warfare of like
Boomers and Gen X versus gen Z and like
it's all very blurry but it's amazing to
me when I look at this how easy this is
to
win it it's there if you're willing to
go there it's there if you care like
it's it's just there meaning for example
I have 2,000 employees I have 2,000
emplo I
spend I don't know 2 three hours a day
on on average with one-on-one meetings
for 15 minutes at a time with employees
at any and every
level this company when I looked at its
growth curve did anybody else notice
like how much revenue it was doing after
10 years and 15 years and then what
happens the commitment the DNA of this
company the founder the way this was
built the biggest opportunity is for you
to actually double down on that DNA in a
contemporary way using the technology of
the day just literally texting somebody
while you're here back in the team
that's done a good job and be like
you're doing a good job I don't think
people understand these micro deposits
how much impact they have it's a big
deal and I know like a lot of the stuff
I talk about sounds like Grandma talk
but it is 100% the game we're playing
because I want to remind people people
are starting to get more and more
options to not work for
you everyone's like gen Z is the genen Z
has
options when everyone's like Jen Z So
Soft I'm like all right take yourself
back to being 23 would you rather have a
job pay you $20 an hour and make
38,000 a year or would you rather make 8
$80,000 a year being an influencer
talking about the things you
want there are more and more options
every day your retention and the way
you're building your teams is a massive
variable and more importantly as I did
my homework the thing I'm most
fascinated by is how this crew interacts
with each
other is such a big variable but the
framework that is set up you have to be
purple cuz if you're looking one way or
the other it's not going to work so it's
it's a huge theme and then I'm going to
bounce to number eight I'm really
interested about this people ask me a
lot of like why did I invest in all
these companies before everyone else did
or why do I and it's completely based on
number eight which is curiosity for
example as I started digging in and
getting more educated this concept of
the one brand Under LinkedIn and they're
going to make content and then what are
you going to do about it I'm pretty sure
that the far majority of the people in
this room are not going to commit the
level of hours in time into reposting
the content that this logo posts on
LinkedIn and add their two cents and
DJing capabilities because you're not
going to see the direct quick r a y on
it right love it
beautiful meanwhile because I've been
following social since 2005 LinkedIn
today from an organic reach and from an
ads Roi standpoint is the most fertile
ground that I've seen since Facebook
2012 especially from a B2B
standpoint you you cannot
comprehend what one thoughtful
two-minute video can do for business
development instead of you hunting it
starts to come to you if you're
committed to content the reality is
is playing a marathon in a sprinter's
world is always challenging but to me
I'm very curious about what percentage
of this group and when I leave I'm going
to there was something I wanted to tell
the guys backstage I'm like whomever in
this room actually goes on the attack
needs to this year needs to be the focal
point of next year's conference because
how much content y'all
make on LinkedIn in
2024 and they're putting you on third
base this is more like a franchisee
franchisor framework than being a pure
entrepreneur or being a pure Corporation
the fact that they're going to put you
on third base and you just get to be a
DJ instead of being an original
songwriter is like huge but it's not
easy like a lot of you are insecure of
how you look on camera and you don't
want to deal with negative feedback say
the wrong thing blah blah blah blah but
if I can leave you with anything besides
self-awareness um I I couldn't push you
harder to before and this is a big thing
on curiosity the biggest thing I'm
fascinated by is why people say no
before they say
maybe I think about this all the time
it's happening right now with AI the
amount of people in this room that have
real opinions about AI because they read
one or two headlines or one of their
friends said something and have done no
homework on it actually is fascinating
to me it's what we do with
technology there's a lot of people in
this actually let's see how honest this
room is cuz I see some gray hairs like I
have in the crowd friends that are a
little bit older in
here how many people remember when they
said that they would never get a cell
phone because their pager and beeper was
good enough raise your hands raise them
high tell the
truth and I'm telling you several are
holding it down how many people here
said they would never go on Facebook
back in 2006 7 and 8 and now have
Facebook raise your
hands mhm
a lot more than that bunch of
Liars I didn't I didn't know that about
you Stockton but I'll take it the bottom
line is literally electricity was
demonized in our society as demons in
your house and people held off and kept
doing candles technology is always
demonized every single person here when
they grasp what AI is and what it means
for sales in 5 years will'll be using it
every day just like a search engine just
like an iPhone this is a big one you
won't lie about this one how many people
said they were never getting an iPhone
because their Blackberry had buttons
that they needed to touch
them that's what I think about what I'm
doing right now is trying to give you
examples of knowing 98% of this room is
going to under poost on LinkedIn next
year and knowing it has a direct
correlation of getting new business
we're the fastest growing agency
independent agency in the world in
advertising our entire business model is
my content on LinkedIn
we have the lowest new business overhead
we spend nothing on sponsorships no
conference events no
booths nothing
LinkedIn
free the world is constantly changing I
I couldn't encourage you enough to
understand what this content means and
what I love about this room is you know
your craft a lot of people struggle with
content because they don't know what
they're talking about and opinions are
fine hot takes are fine but actually
going into deep work like if you and by
the way not everybody has to do audio or
video written word is written word is
phenomenal if you're awkward or
embarrassed or you don't want to make
that jump I get it but you can do
written word you do three powerful IND
detailed sentences paragraphs on top of
content you will be stunned I just
encourage you greatly because the only
thing that is universal in our society
is that who Whoever has the attention
has the
leverage you know what's going on in the
world it's called the media
infrastructure in our society has
shifted have you ever wondered why when
there's a coup in a country a coup data
that while they go to the Palace to get
the guy or the gal they also go to the
newspaper radio station and TV station
whoever controls the message has the
leverage for the first time in history
we as human individuals have the ability
to have scale I get more consumption on
my link in then CNBC gets viewers
real real that's absurd that makes no
sense not the way we all grew up this is
a massive opportunity and so I highly
encourage you don't need to do it but
don't just be no before you said maybe
spend five you know if you want to grow
your business I think it's worth five
hours of actually really tasting it
because we are unbelievable headline
readers in America we are we got all you
have unlimited opinions about stuff that
you've never even spent an hour
researching got it
cool all right I think um I think when I
look at this list and I look at this
room and I really really very honestly
want to go into Q&A about it um I'm
going to touch on a couple of other
things here quickly but I do want to
talk about and I noticed over there and
I appreciate it when I talked about like
texting someone and just saying like
you're doing a good job I I do want to
talk a little bit about kindness It's
such a fluffy word in such a business
environment
but I'm going to actually tell you a
story and then hopefully use it to tie
it back so I'm running Wine Library for
my dad in the mid 2000s at this point
and it's going extremely well and we're
milking Google AdWords we're milking
Direct Mail we're milking email
marketing and it's like you know I could
sense that we were getting stale and I
was trying to think about how to really
win our lifetime value and I'm very
aware that your business is incredibly
good at lifetime value once you get them
in it's hard to unwind which is why it's
a good business which is why you guys
have made some
paper but I want to talk not about your
customers though I'm not against it I'll
get into that in actually I'm sorry now
I realizes I'm about to tell you the
story this may have a lot to do with
your current clients and how it impacts
you getting more clients let me just
tell you the story and then we'll wind
it back and then please anything we've
talked about or anything else you know
about me or anything else we will get
into Q&A but here's why I believe in
kindness and why I believe in the world
we live now with on the internet and
things of that nature so it's like
200 I don't know 11 9 when this happened
maybe
10 so I say to the team internally I
want you to Google every single person
that buys something on wine library.com
every day to try to find them on the
Internet so we're talking about 4 or 500
people a day on average some days are
2,000 some days are a little lower and
like if David bought you know Gary V CH
easy very unique name obviously James
Smith might be hard but we know the
address everything so we start looking
and I told the team that when you find
four or five people that you really know
and cuz it was an early like process and
project for me I said if you name if you
find a customer who's bought for the
first time and they bought something
significantly interesting or something
like just tell me first couple days go
by and there just doesn't click so then
I email the team and say hey just send
me anybody that you've able to identify
so they identify this gentleman in
Chicago anybody from
Chicago Jesus Christ oh there we go
three okay
Chicago um they identified the gentleman
from
Chicago who bought a case of Santa
Margarita
pinia which is by the way quick
Sidetrack on wine Santa Margarita pinio
is literally the most overrated wine in
the world straight garbage for 22 bucks
but everybody buys it cuz it's a brand
so if you're buying Santa Margarita
pinio please
stop you can buy better panio for like
12 bucks or buy newal and 7 block but
we'll go into that
later they find this dude it's $150
order or 200 bucks it's
tiny we find him on the internet we find
his Twitter account we go to his Twitter
account every one of his posts are about
Jay
Cutler
so clearly enough people know who that
is but for the ones that don't know Jake
Cutler was the bearest quarterback at
the time and it's like Jay Cutler you're
the best I love you Jay Cutler and then
obviously some would while he was
watching no Jay Cutler why'd you throw
that Jay Cutler this J Cutler that
anyway I tell the team to go to eBay and
buy this man a
$350 J Cutler sign Jersey and send it to
his home and I want him to write a
detailed note that says thank you for
shopping for the first time because it
was his first order too first time at
Wine LAB basically I think everyone here
is seeing what I'm setting up I'm trying
to figure out if there was a marketing
PL now that we could find people on the
internet in 2010 to do surprise and
Delight that I could see a correlation
to lifetime value against the investment
scale the unscalable something I'm
obsessed with that I would like you to
do for your employees and former clients
but we'll get into that in a minute I'm
pumped I'm like the dude bought like a
$200 case of wine for the first time is
about to get like a $400 jersey in the
mail and this dude is obsessed with Jay
Cutler right so I'm like this is going
to be the greatest so we send it and I'm
telling you for the next three weeks I
come into the office I'm like did the
dude call did he buy like where is it
nothing I'm boarding a plane to go to
Napa Valley I get a call from the office
that're I Gary you you there I'm like
hey I'm about to board they're like I'm
like can I call you when I land they're
like no I'm like what happened I thought
something bad they're like you're never
going to believe this I'm like what and
then it clicked I'm like the Jay color
guide
no they go let us just read this they
read me this order was just placed by a
first-time customer in Plano Texas the
guy bought $8,000 of red
burgundy but in the notes he left the
note he said hey first time order can
you hold this it's really hot in Texas
can you ship this in the
fall number two I just want you guys to
know you have great prices on red
burgundy like I'd like to get more
here's the other stuff number three I
think it's really cool what you did for
my friend in Chicago he told me about
the story of the Jay Cutler jersey
number four Ps I'm a huge Bruce
Springsteen
fan two books prior to this I wrote a
book called The thank you economy it
talks about scaling unscalable Behavior
in the framework of kindness to make
money I am here today talking to you
about business I am not talking about
nonprofit I am not talking about foofy
poofiness or how we should feel I'm
talking about understanding emotional
intelligence as a platform to grow your
actual business I am convinced that
business people in 2023 do not deploy
enough compassion and empathy and
sympathy for their teams I believe it
and I believe that if this group leaves
this talk whomever decides to allocate
an hour a day instead of let's talk
about one of my biggest pet peeves
meetings meetings are the worst here's
why there's not a meeting going on right
now in this country that isn't booked
for an hour that's really a 20-minute
meeting we just fill it with dumb
if you just take two of your 1hour
meetings a day and cut it to 30 30 and
take back that hour and redeploy it to
have an actual relationship with the
people that work on your team or across
the platform or if you want to allocate
it to the content creation this tripling
down on culture and content is the
Battleground the Battleground right now
in 2024 for business is who is going to
out content who and number two who is
going to out retention and acquire
teammates
and that is the framework of this
conversation that is why I wrote this
book I know that the in these 13 traits
that I think have mapped and this is not
a life story this is obviously got a lot
of what I do but I was a massively early
investor in some of the most successful
companies in the world and the ones I
passed on Airbnb and many others I'm
close to and I watch them plus I have
the Pepsis and the chases I have a 360
view on a lot of businesses at this
point and when I tell you that these
things and balancing them the reason I
used it if you look at the bottom where
I say leveraging the emotional
ingredients the key when you are
managing clients or employees is
understanding it's not one
thing it's cooking a meal your top
performer like like do you understand
that if the number one person back home
that's in charge of retention or
servicing is out that changes your
variable
so much of us and so many of us are way
more vulnerable to one or two people to
completely wipe out a year and yet we
don't put any effort and commitment into
it and those people need some
combination of
this and understanding how to balance
these different things I mean I'll give
you one number nine and 12 is how I live
my life do you know how much this
confuses my audience in social media do
you know that I put out outrageous
levels of cont content around patience
do you know how much I believe that if
you're 59 years old that you're just at
halftime and you can completely pivot
yet every under 30-year-old that follows
me thinks that if they don't have their
life figured out tomorrow they're
finished but how you balance and this
one's for you instead of spending time
on your team and your partners number
nine and 12 is your life the people in
this room that figure out how to balance
patience and
ambition will win I think about things
like this time of year some of you are
going to do something to hit certain
numbers in this year that will actually
hurt you for next year but you put the
pedestal of the number that you
arbitrarily created for yourself for
this year and you will completely
up growth in 24 internally on your team
or externally just for an arbitrary hit
on this p&l year makes no sense complete
lack of patience happens all the time
and and so look I came here with real
purpose today which is like really start
to have conversations about different
things that I don't think we spend
enough time on and I believe that the
companies that I see really accelerating
in these last 2 three years and
definitely what I see going forward are
going to find these
balances on culture and content and I
hope this brought some value to somebody
today thank
[Applause]
you
oh